I think it's interesting to think about
what if we started every design and
technology company or every design and
technology product that we're creating
with three questions and the first
question is what is really desirable
about this thing? The second question is
for whom?
So who are we really designing for? And
we do an okay job of asking those first
two questions. But the third question is:
who we are not designing for? I teach my
students that design is ongoing risky
decision making. And what I mean by
ongoing is that you never really get to
stop questioning the assumptions that
you're making that are underlying what
it is that you're creating, those
fundamental premises. Things change, you
change, the market changes and you have
to like have as part of your practice
an ongoing process of revisiting those
fundamental assumptions. So in the
academic community we have these
rigorous standards for the ethical
reviews that we must go through before
we publish, before we even undertake
research that we might publish. An
example of that
so if you look at like that you might
have seen Facebook's emotional contagion
study. And they came under a lot of
criticism when people realized that they
were manipulating the sort of emotional
emotional tenor of people's feeds. And
that is an example of a study that would
have never passed academic ethical
review boards. And what's really
interesting is that in this professional
population, the academic population, we've
decided on a value system in terms of
what is ethical to do to people who are
active participants in the study, and
people who are passive participants or
non-participants of the study.
And in business, and particularly in the
tech community, there's a notable absence
of a similar review system And these
types of decisions of who we designed
for and who we don't design for; these
are ultimately values decisions.
They're very messy, like there's no answer
about who we should and should not
design for. The answer is to continue to
have that dialogue and continue to have
the basic information that we need to
have that dialogue, for designers to have that dialogue, for funders to be part
of that dialogue, for you know young
students fresh out of school deciding
who to work for to be able to have that
dialogue, for consumers to be able to
have that dialogue about what
value systems they want to support with
their business. We need that
continuous ongoing questioning of
design assumptions and decisions.